bo never knew his parents and we never
had kids
if i didn't stay if i left
it would be like he never existed
i couldn't pack up and move on
he loved empire he loved his work
so much he loved being there everybody
loved him
so i stayed same town
same house
it's like my dad used to say what's
remembered
lives
i maybe spent too much of my life just
remembering
you know what i mean i can
i can relate um i rarely ever
talk about my son but
today would be
today would be his 33rd birthday and
five years ago he took his life
and i can still barely say that in a
sentence
and and for a long time
every day was
the question was how can i be alive on
this earth
when he's not
and i didn't have an answer
and those were some hard hard days
but
i realized that i could honor him by
uh helping people and serving people
it gives me a reason to go through the
day
some days that's all i've got
and out here there's a lot of people our
age and inevitably there's grief and
loss
and a lot of them don't get over it
either and that's okay
that's okay one of the things i love
most about this life
is that there's no final goodbye
you know i've met hundreds of people out
here and
i don't ever say a final goodbye i
always just say
i'll see you down the road and i do
and whether it's a month or a year or
sometimes years
i see them again i can look down the
road and i can be
certain in my heart that i'll see my son
again
you'll see beau again and you can
remember
your lives together then
bye